well october is breast cancer awareness
month and one out of every eight women
will be diagnosed with breast cancer in
their lifetime you likely know someone
who has or maybe you have yourself
the disease kills tens of thousands of
women in the u.s every year
while experts say black women are
slightly less likely to be diagnosed
with breast cancer
they do face a greater risk of dying
from the disease according to doctors
the disparity is seen for all
socioeconomic backgrounds
so studying genetics and biology of
breast cancer
is critical back in the day we sort of
attributed
a lot to access to care and certainly
access to care plays a role
but we now know that there are many
reasons and many causes
and a lot of research is underway to
address those causes
really important and experts are
concerned that the pandemic will widen
the gap
as many women are delaying getting
screened they encourage all women to
talk to their doctors about when to
start getting checked
john all right